QUARANTINE OF THE STATES WHICH
HE NOW SAYS IS NOT NECESSARY.
JOINING ME RIGHT NOW IS HOUSE
MINORITY LEADER KEVIN MCCARTHY
AND CONGRESSMAN ALWAYS A
PLEASURE TO SEE YOU THANKS FOR
BEING HERE.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME BACK
ON.
MARIA: SO IS IT NECESSARY TO
HAVE THESE LOCKDOWNS ON
OBVIOUSLY THE TRI-STATE AREA AND
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY AT THIS
POINT?
>> I THINK IT IS NECESSARY,
BECAUSE WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
NUMBER OF DEATHS BUT ALSO
THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS THAT
HAVE IT A LARGE PORTION OF THAT
IS FROM THE TRI-STATE AND THE
TREASURY IS TRYING TO GET
AHEAD OF IT JUST AS HE MADE
THE SMART DECISION FOR STOPPING
FLIGHTS FROM CHINA COMING IN AS
WELL.
THESE ARE PROTECTIONS FOR THE
REST OF THE NATION.
MARIA: LET’S TALK ABOUT THAT
RELIEF BILL THAT YOU AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES WORKED ON THE
PRESIDENT SIGNING INTO LAW.
CAN YOU WALK US THROUGH WHAT’S
MOST IMPORTANT AND WHAT YOU
BELIEVE WILL ACTUALLY MOVE THE
NEEDLE ON ECONOMIC GROWTH
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT WE MAY VERY
WELL BE IN A RECESSION RIGHT NOW
>> THIS IS VERY CRITICAL AND
IT’S MORE THAN A RESCUE.
IT’S ACTUALLY A COMMITMENT FROM
YOUR GOVERNMENT.
I WISH WE WOULD HAVE HAD THIS A
WEEK AGO.
UNFORTUNATELY DEMOCRATS HELD US
UP BUT LET’S WALK THROUGH THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS.
FIRST IT PROVIDES $140 BILLION
TO THE HOSPITALS.
THIS IS DIRECTLY SO THEY GET
LIQUIDITY BUT ALSO FOR THAT
PERSONAL PROTECTION EQUIPMENT
THAT IS SO CRITICAL, BECAUSE OUR
MEDICAL COMMUNITY IS REALLY THE
MODERN DAY SOLDIER, IN THE
VIRUS WE’RE BATTLING BUT FOR
THE SMALL BUSINESS OWNER WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE’RE KEEPING
PEOPLE EMPLOYED.
IF YOU ARE A SMALL BUSINESS, 500
EMPLOYEES TO JUST A WORKER
YOURSELF YOU’LL GET A GUARANTEED
LOAN FROM GOVERNMENT FOR 2.5
TIMES YOUR PAYROLL.
IF YOU USE THAT MONEY TO PAY
YOUR EMPLOYEES, IF YOU ALREADY
LAID THEM OFF, BRING THEM BACK
AND PAY THEM, PAY YOUR RENT, PAY
YOUR UTILITIES, AND THAT IS
FORGIVEN NO LONGER A LOAN BUT I
GRANT.
IF YOU ARE A LARGER BUSINESS,
YOU GET A GUARANTEED LOAN BUT
YOU ALSO GET A RETENTION PROGRAM
IN THERE, THROUGH A TAX
ADVANTAGE THAT GOVERNMENT WILL
PAY FOR HALF OF YOUR EMPLOYEE
SALARY.
THAT’S AN ABILITY TO KEEP PEOPLE
WORKING.
THEN THE INDIVIDUAL CHECKS THAT
WILL GO AND START IN THREE WEEKS
, $1,200 PER PERSON, 2,400
PER COUPLE, 500 PER CHILD, IT’LL
START PHASING DOWN AFTER EARNING
$75,000.
THIS IS CRITICAL TO GET US
THROUGH THE NEXT TWO MONTHS AND
GET THIS ECONOMY COMING BACK
JUST LIKE A HOCKEY STICK LOOKS
LIKE.
WE’LL HAVE A COUPLE TOUGH MONTHS
MARIA: SO THIS IS THE NEXT TWO
MONTHS.
YOU SAID THAT --
>> YES.
MARIA: YOU SAID THE NEXT TWO
MONTHS AND SECRETARY MNUCHIN
SAID THE SAME THING, 10-12 WEEKS
TO ADDRESS THE DISLOCATION SO
DOES THAT MEAN WE’RE GETTING
ANOTHER STIMULUS, A FOURTH
PACKAGE AFTER THE NEXT 10-12
WEEKS?
>> I’M NOT SURE WE NEED A
FOURTH PACKAGE AND BEFORE WE GO
TO START DRAFTING A FORTH
PACKAGE I’D LIKE THESE THREE
PACKAGES WE JUST PUT OUT.
REMEMBER IT’S MORE THAN
$2 TRILLION THE LARGEST WE’VE
EVER SEEN, TO TAKE CARE AND GET
THIS ECONOMY MOVING.
REMEMBER FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE, WE’RE ADDING ANOTHER
$600 ABOVE WHAT YOUR STATE PAYS,
WE START PAYING IN THE FIRST
WEEK, AND WE GIVE YOU ADDITIONAL
13 WEEKS.
WHAT CONCERNS ME IS WHEN I
LISTEN TO NANCY PELOSI TALK
ABOUT A FOURTH PACKAGE NOW,
BECAUSE SHE DID NOT GET IN THE
THINGS SHE REALLY WANTED, TO
CHANGE THE ELECTION LAW, A GREEN
NEW DEAL, MAKE US PAY FOR
PLANNED PARENTHOOD, AND
EXPAND WHAT YOU’RE SEEING FOR
SANCTUARY CITIES.
THOSE ARE THE THINGS WHY THIS
BILL WAS HELD UP FOR A WEEK
BUT THE THINGS WE SAW.
MARIA: THAT IS SO OUTRAGEOUS
THAT YOU WERE ACTUALLY BEING
ASKED TO CONSIDER FUNDING
PLANNED PARTICIPANTHOOD, AT A
TIME THAT WE ARE IN THIS CRISIS
SITUATION WHERE YOU’RE TRYING TO
COME UP WITH A RELIEF PACKAGE.
I WANT TO SHARE WHAT NANCY
PELOSI SAID THIS MORNING
CONGRESSMAN BECAUSE SHE IS JUST
SAYING RIGHT NOW.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DENIAL AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS WAS DEADLY AND
THAT RIGHT NOW AS HE FIDDLES,
HER WORDS, AS HE FIDDLES, PEOPLE
ARE DYING.
THIS IS WHAT NANCY PELOSI SAID
THIS MORNING.
YOUR REACTION?
>> WELL WHAT I SEE IS THAT
NANCY IS TRYING TO COVER HERSELF
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY BECAUSE
THE AMOUNT OF DAMAGE THAT HE HAD
JUST DONE IN THE LAST WEEK,
REQUESTING ABOUT CHANGING
ELECTION LAW, THAT HER NUMBER
THREE IN HER OWN PARTY SAID THEY
WANTED TO RESTRUCTURE GOVERNMENT
, TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY
OF A CRISIS, AND MARIA WHAT
HAPPENED LAST WEEK, 3.2
AMERICANS LOST THEIR JOB, SIX
TIMES HIGHER THAN THE FINANCIAL
CRISIS, HIGHER THAN THE GREAT
DEPRESSION ALL BECAUSE DEMOCRATS
WANTED TO PUT THEIR LIBERAL
PARTS IN, BUT THIS PRESIDENT
FOUGHT FOR IT.
THIS PRESIDENT STOPPED THAT AND
WHAT’S MOST IMPORTANTLY IS
HISTORY WILL NOT BE KIND TO THE
DEMOCRATS.
HOLDING UP THAT WEEK WAS SO
CRITICAL.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE ACTION THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP TOOK THE CHINESE
BE COMING INTO AMERICA, OR
EUROPE AS WELL AND THEIR OWN
PARTY CRITICIZED THE PRESIDENT
FOR DOING THOSE ACTIONS, BUT IT
SAVED THOUSANDS OF LIVES JUST AS
HE WANTED TO MOVE THIS BILL.
I WAS SITTING IN THAT MEETING
LAST SUNDAY.
THIS BILL WAS 99% WHERE IT WAS
LAST SUNDAY BUT NANCY PELOSI
HELD IT UP, BRAGGED TO HER
MEMBERS IN THE IDEA OF CHANGING
GREEN NEW DEAL, PLANNED PARENT
HOOD, CHANGING ELECTION LAW AND
EXPANDING SANCTUARY CITIES,
NOTHING TO DO WITH CORONAVIRUS.
THEY DID GET 24 MILLION MORE
DOLLARS FOR THE KENNEDY CENTER.
MARIA: IT’S INCREDIBLE, YES
EXACTLY 25 MILLION FOR THE
KENNEDY CENTER AND YET
SHE TELLS A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
STORY YOU KNOW SHE SAID SHE DID
JU JITSU ON THE PLAN, SHE
SAID, TO CHANGE IT TO GET IT
WHERE IT IS AND THEN OF COURSE
YOU’VE GOT ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ AND WHAT SHE SAID
ON FRIDAY, WATCH THIS AND GET
YOUR REACTION, CONGRESSMAN.
>> WHAT DID THE SENATE MAJORITY
FIGHT FOR , ONE OF THE LARGEST
CORPORATE BAIL OUTS WITH AS FEW
STRINGS AS POSSIBLE IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
SHAMEFUL.
THE DEGREE OF THAT FIGHT IS
WRONG.
MARIA: YOU SAW THAT.
YOUR REACTION?
>> YEAH, WELL IT’S NOT A TIME
FOR THEATRICS.
THIS IS TIME TO ACTUALLY GET THE
BILL DONE BUT IF YOU
LISTEN TO THESE DEMOCRATS THAT
IS EXACTLY WHAT THEY WANT TO DO.
THEY ARE MORE CONCERNED ABOUT A
FOREIGN COUNTRY OR  FOREIGN
INDIVIDUAL THAN THEY ARE ABOUT
AMERICA THEMSELVES AND NOT ONLY
DO WE HAVE TO FIGHT THIS.
REMEMBER THE VIRUS IS HERE.
WE DID NOT INVITE IT.
WE DID NOT ASK FOR IT BUT WE
WILL DEFEAT IT TOGETHER AND
THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT THIS BILL
DOES.
UNFORTUNATELY WE WERE HELD UP A
WEEK BY THE DEMOCRATS.
99% OF THIS BILL WAS DONE LAST
WEEK.
IT’S EXACTLY THE SAME FROM THE
13 EXTRA WEEKS FROM THE
SMALL BUSINESS FROM THE
LARGE BUSINESS FROM THE
HOSPITALS BUT PELOSI IS IN
TROUBLE BASED UPON HURTING
AMERICA BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
RESTRUCTURE THIS TO LOOK MORE
LIKE THE SOCIAL VIEWS THEY
BELIEVE IN.
MARIA: SO LET’S END ON SOME
OPTIMISM, CONGRESSMAN BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT YOU HAD A PHONE CALL
THIS MORNING WITH MANAGERS OF
BUSINESSES, CEO’S IN THE PHARMA
SECTOR
TELL US WHAT YOU’RE EXPECTING
AND THIS FEELS LIKE THE NEWFOUND
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
BUSINESS AND GOVERNMENTS RIGHT
NOW.
I KNOW THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN CALLING LOTS OF DIFFERENT
GROUPS, CEO’S TO THE WHITE HOUSE
TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW
BUSINESS CAN HELP HERE.
WHAT HAVE YOU LEARNED?
>> THIS IS A GREAT THING ABOUT
AMERICA, THE INGENUITY.
I WAS TALKING TO A CONSORTIUM
FROM THE VERY BEST MEDICAL
INDIVIDUALS TO THE VERY HIGHEST
CEO’S WORKING TOGETHER WITH
GOVERNMENT TO GET THAT PERSONAL
PROTECTION EQUIPMENT COMING INTO
AMERICA, AND AS WE KNOW, CHINA
HAS GOTTEN A LARGE PORTION O OF
THAT SUPPLY CHAIN.
UNFORTUNATELY WE JUST FOUND OUT
ONE OF THE HIGHEST CEO’S TOLD ME
SHE CAME IN AND TOOK ONE OF OUR
FACTORIES WHERE WE WERE
PURCHASING MILLIONS OF THE
EQUIPMENT TO COME HERE TO
GIVE IT TO FRANCE BECAUSE THEY
ARE TRYING TO TAKE MORE OF THE
MARKET SHARE FOR HUAWEI THAT
FRANCE WILL AGREE TO ALLOW
HUAWEI INTO THEIR INDUSTRY ONCE
AGAIN FROM THE EQUIPMENT TO
USING THIS TRAGIC SITUATION TO
GET MORE OF THE SUPPLY CHAIN IN
ANOTHER INDUSTRY.
BUT WHAT WE’RE SEEING IN AMERICA
, LOOK AT WHAT ABBOTT
JUST CAME OUT THIS WEEK, THAT
THEY HAVE A NEW ABILITY TO GET A
TEST RESULTS FOR CORONAVIRUS IN
AS FAST AS FIVE MINUTES.
WE’RE ALREADY INTO A TRIAL ONE
TEST FOR A VIRUS.
THE INGENUITY OF AMERICA WILL
OVERCOME THIS.
WE WILL BE STRONGER.
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THE SUPPLY
CHAIN, SOMETHING THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP HAS TOLD US ABOUT FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING.
CHINA HAS TOO MUCH CONTROL OF
OUR MEDICAL EQUIPMENT, TOO MUCH
CONTROL WHEN IT COMES TO
PHARMACEUTICALS, TOO MUCH
CONTROL OF CRITICAL MINERALS.
WE’VE GOT TO TAKE THIS BACK AND
KEEP IT INSIDE AMERICA SO WE CAN
COMBAT NOT ONLY THIS BUT OTHER
THINGS IN THE FUTURE.
MARIA: DEFINITELY ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT LESSONS FROM
ALL OF THIS HOW MINORITY LEADER